our DVDs will be in Walmart which is
significant because Walmart is sort of
the last man standing right it's the
last place where there's really
meaningful sales of DVDs when people
shifted from buying dvds to streaming
movies there was a big collapse in
revenues for indie films so think of it
this way average DVD costs what ten to
fifteen dollars right average streaming
is what three to five dollars or think
how many more people need to stream a
movie to make up for that deficit for
the same amount of revenue to come back
to the distributor to the filmmaker you
need easily ten times as many people
seeing the film so when you are small
film and you have a limited audience to
begin with you're collapsing the revenue
the reason that there was such a kind of
a huge fecundity in the late 80s and 90s
with the advent of the VHS and then DVD
that suddenly created this whole revenue
stream for independent film so that more
could then be funded and produced when
that collapsed the whole business model
collapsed making a lot harder to make
our films and certainly to get them out
there with meaningful distribution so
this is a super exciting opportunity for
Jack of the red hearts for our
filmmaking team and I hope for a lot of
other filmmakers to follow
you